the first doses of the single shot
johnson and johnson vaccine are bringing
hope and relief to communities
all across the country today the ohio
state university in columbus was
one of the first places to get started
and our lead national correspondent
david begno is there david good morning
to you
it's an exciting moment for people yeah
sure was and say it again you only need
one dose of the vaccine that's the game
changer here with j and j look here in
columbus they reportedly got
300 doses yesterday and they said let's
do a trial run right away
and just like that barbara
schmollenberger became one of the very
first people in the united states
to receive the johnson johnson vaccine i
can't believe it's over
she was one of five people to get the
shot at the ohio state university on
tuesday
and going forward ohioans will be able
to choose which shot they want
what we're going to do is try and figure
out why are people choosing
one versus the other so it can help us
determine the best way to use this in
the future
and then there are the people like 84
year old nancy heber
johnson johnson shot was really her only
option she has several allergies to
different medicines
including the solution that turns the
freeze-dried moderna and pfizer vaccines
into a liquid so while she's been
eligible for months
her doctor said you need to wait for j j
i thought
when is it going to be my turn i am so
thrilled that today was my day for
freedom
freedom to see her family again like her
87 year old sister who lives down the
street
she just started her vaccinations too
and her 35 year old grandson who is
developmentally disabled
he'll get his second shot this week but
heber says she's most excited to see her
son brian
she hasn't seen him in two years we do
talk on the phone every night but in
person
it's just the best ever i grew up during
world war
ii i didn't see my dad for four years
so i know what being away from loved
ones is about
at 84 i realized my time to be around
is limited and so to be able to make
plans
to see someone i haven't seen for two
years
that means an awful lot
you gotta love that miss nancy she's a
retired teacher
listen if you have severe allergies like
her j j might be the right one for you i
mean in clinical trials
it was proven to be 100 percent
effective
at preventing hospitalizations and
deaths but if you don't have a severe
allergy like miss nancy
doctors say j j moderna or pfizer
is the right one for you david i am so
with you on miss nancy may we all feel
that happiness that was great to see
thank you so much the us amen is right